Cómo estará de complicada la situación
que algunos congresistas se reunieron
hace pocas horas con el Primer Ministro
Alberto tárola y le dijeron que se
encuentran entrampados y necesitan más
tiempo para lograr un acuerdo en la
propuesta de adelanto de elecciones
requiere 87 votos para ser aprobada pero
si no consigue Esto será derivada a una
segunda legislatura que comienza el 15
de febrero y si no consigue al menos el
2% de dos tercios de votos de los
parlamentos pero si llegase a reunir 66
votos recién se podría hablar de un
referéndum los expertos señalan que el
referéndum en el mejor de los casos
podría ejecutarse recién dentro de
cuatro meses y Para ello se requiere 180
millones de dólares del erario peruano
por otro lado algunos congresistas están
señalando que la salida más viable sería
aplicar un impeachment a la presidenta
Dina boluarte Alejandro aguinaga
congresista del partido fujimorista
fuerza particular afirma que sometiendo
a boluarte a un proceso de vacancia
presidencial recién se podría hablar
verdaderamente de un adelanto de
elecciones Francisco ahora cómo van las
protestas y los bloqueos qué
repercusiones negativas están generando
los reclamos
justamente la superintendencia nacional
de transportes en su último reporte
señala que existen 72 74 puntos de
tránsito interrumpidos y 15 vías
nacionales afectadas la protestas no
paran tampoco los bloqueos y en esa
línea el Ministerio de comercio ha
afirmado que las protestas están
generando pérdidas a los pequeños y
medianas empresas por 32 millones de
dólares por cada día de paralizaciones
por su parte el Instituto Nacional de
estadística revela que los disturbios
están generando pérdidas
a todos los sectores del país y eso ha
motivado a la inflación aumente en esa
línea señala que se ha generado una
inflación temporalmente más alta en
enero la cifra ha llegado a
8.67% y el fútbol tampoco escapa a esta
afectación los disturbios han motivado
las autoridades a suspender el campeona
Distrito Nacional de la Liga 1 los
clubes los futbolistas Y en especial los
hinchas se encuentran muy contrariados